you know I did watch this casino that
was a [__] good movie [__] yeah
that's a good one yeah that whole this
whole like era of mob movies it's just
hard to beat they all just feel so good
they don't make films like they used to
man yeah
truly don't they don't really because
they don't be doing real stunts anymore
everything's CGI yeah you see that video
of uh
um [__]
God damn who's the [__] Main
Jesus Christ
what's the fighter pilot movie Top Gun
Top Gun who started Top Gun
foreign
Tom Cruise did you see the video of him
like dropping out of the plane filming
that video
that was pretty insane was it not yeah
that's why Tom you know yeah that is
insane dude he really does the those
[__] crazy ass stunts what's the
craziest thing you've done for a project
man I haven't really done anything that
wild no I mean um in your honor I
[__] um there was a scene where I
like
I I jump out of like a second story
window oh yeah I did that stunt that was
cool they had me like harnessed in and
I'm like hanging on to the edge of the
the the the roof and then I just dropped
myself down I fall down and break my leg
they had me on like a harness yeah that
was that was a cool stunt but I've done
crazier stunts just in like real life
yeah what yeah
man oh yeah yeah yeah really in my
Harley what do you think you were more
what do you think you got more
adrenaline from jumping out that window
on the harness or just oh the Harley for
sure yeah for sure Fallen doing that no
I actually never have I never have were
you it's like BMX little kid or anything
no no I was I I was I snowboarded but
that's it I was a terrible skater bro I
couldn't skate for [__] so what gave you
the confidence to pull a wheelie man
that [__] is I was like obsessed with it
dude because I was riding around
actually like my co-host Josh should be
pulling up any second he he taught me
hey Josh
come over here dude
he taught me how to wheelie right
because because we'd be riding around
and he is like a [__] wheelie Master
okay and I would just feel like such a
[__] if I couldn't wheelie so I really
wanted because they'd all be wheelie and
I'd just be like riding my bike like
oh thanks dude
yeah what's up dude what's up man here
tell a story about tell a story about me
learning how to wheelie how to wheelie
yeah
tell them the story about me learning
how to wheelie
see look you guys see that video of me
Wheeling right there
all right so how did I took that video
by the way okay so were you doing a
wheelie too filming him doing I'm sure
I'm sure yeah he films me I filmed him
you know uh but the I remember the first
time he started to do wheelies it was
really sketchy yeah it was really really
sketchy man he uh he had he's got a lot
Ascend in him to be honest look at that
yeah that's a that's a 700 pound bike
you know yeah so dude what you're
supposed to do is you throw your chair
back a little bit
the theory on a wheelie okay is that you
know you clutch it up you go slow as
possible first gear you could you know
other bikes are different with the
Harley you know it's a lot of torques I
hadn't like you get in first gear you
throw it up you know you dump the clutch
give it a lot of throttle throw it up
and then once you get so far back I mean
you're either falling or you're gonna
touch the back brake and that'll bring
you forward and give a little throttle
and then a little break and then you
start balancing it out and dude he got
it faster than probably anybody I've
ever ridden with yeah no I was literally
like obsessed with it like I I literally
like didn't I didn't care about anything
in life but learning how to literally
every day out there I would just be
riding around on my bike for hours until
I got it down just always on a wheelie
or we have a buddy named CJ
who's also he's he's probably one of the
best Harley stunt riders in the world
meaning like these dudes that like
wheelie Harleys and do like crazy ass
like tricks on Harleys and [__] our
buddy CJ was just down and they they did
a ride down in Tijuana
and um they got in a high-speed chase
with the cops down there and like all of
them got away except our buddies CJ he
like he CR he like fell up is like he
crashed his bike and the cops got him
and um they planted a gun on him they
they got him they they threw a dirty gun
on him and and and tried to violate him
for like a gun charge in Mexico and he
had to go to Mexican prison wow for like
I thought he beat it like two months for
like two months like that yeah and they
whooped his ass he was stuck in Mexican
prison we all had to like do a
fundraiser like to like for like we
ought to like do like charity events to
raise money because they were trying to
that the cops were just like wanted a
bribe to get him out of there his dad
was paying like 20 30 000 at a time I
think he did it a couple times just to
get him out yeah wow he ended up paying
like like 30 30. just straight cat 30
yeah to bust him out Mexican prison
break with a bunch of cash you know so
he brought it by hand to Tijuana yeah
his dad did that's crazy yeah do you
still ride chat yeah okay yeah we just
rode two days ago yeah nice yeah I've
I've always wanted to just like
it's not really a Harley but like a
Diavel or something are you right
I want to but I know how honestly uh the
clothes I've been a motorcycle engine is
like I've driven like a race car that
uses a motorcycle engine but no cool uh
next Sunday you guys wanna I think
people ask them dude I literally teach
people I'm down to learn yeah I've
always uh I've always wanted like an 848
just like a Ducati or something I know
that's like the [__] dude just wait
till you I I used to say the same thing
I used to be like just a street bike guy
yeah and check out this Harley and like
I kind of sat and I was like I didn't
want to tell him like this thing feels
nice and comfy I was like oh it's all
right you know yeah it opens my 954.
yeah but uh but dude then like once you
get down to Harley yeah uh I'm 22 no
32.9 camera like all those chicks are
like these tickets are still there
are you ticklish
um yeah I think a little bit
see it's a disarming Club it really is
you're right it humanizes it humanizes
anything how tall are you uh six four
six four
a half my Bumble says six four though
but but he's ticklish sometimes yeah I'm
ticklish you know if I get tickled I'm
tickless yeah I guess yeah there's no
way to like answer that question
it depends on who's tickling me I think
I'm in that camp if I tickle you would
you let's not find out
that was great dudes uh thanks for the
tea by the way ooh long bro I think we
gotta wrap it up yeah we do gotta rap
but um yeah this is great man we'll
figure out a bike session I'm actually
[__] down for that yeah it's gonna be
fun watch you guys gonna end up getting
your own bugs we're all gonna be
cruising together yeah fast forward six
months I was already looking at a
[__] Polaris so don't do that dude
why get a Harley
no no no about that I just want a trike
like three bro you can't talk like that
it's back like his back is back we don't
allow you to try to pack with us with
the with the three weeks I'll be there
we can
you're not gonna even if you don't
invite me I'll just pull up hey guys I
got the back I got the real split
traffic so fast to leave you bro no I'm
sure he wouldn't we wouldn't he'll split
traffic yeah
it'd be flipping them over guys hold up
for me you have an open face helmet
wait what do you got against open face
helmets I wear those no I'm just saying
yeah
you know that's like the [__] it just
squeezes your face all crazy small
helmets Yeah
what's your podcast gonna be called the
Chet Hank show the Chet Hank show too
co-host Josh
couple weeks tune in couple weeks yeah
hell yeah it's gonna be big
uh Josh of the Jungle Josh of the Jungle
yeah and Chad Hanks you can't miss it um
hey you should do the Trump real quick
for everybody dude excuse me excuse me I
gotta I really gotta like warm in so I
do a pretty good Trump impression yeah
as you all know I'm running for
president again it's gonna be so great
and my motto My slogan is gonna be make
America great again
excuse me Rosie
O'Donnell she's a dog
Rosie O'Donnell she is not gonna like it
but I'm not surprised are you surprised
first I'm not surprised at all she's a
dog excuse me it's so disgusting excuse
me
that's great I'm running for breath what
the tiny meat gang
gang cast I can't relate to it at all I
can relate to it at all
I'm just being honest folks we all know
I don't I don't have small hands they're
actually thick pens they're very big
they're big hands can relate to it but
it's been a ball I've had a great time
but if Stormy Daniels or maybe Melania
Millennials tickling me then I might
giggle a little bit I don't know
all right I'm done oh you did not bro